et oui alors vous ne rêvez pas nous
sommes bien mardi à d'habitude c'est le
jeudi à les questions en 4/3 jean luc
lemoine aujourd'hui c'est mardi pourquoi
mardi parce que mardi pour l'ornement
c'est un beau jour également exactement
je pense qu'on n'aura pas mieux qu'eux
mais alors résolu vous allez donc
décrypter tout ce qui se passe dans
cette émission à l'aide des images qu'on
voit notamment pendant les coupures pub
j'aimerais que mes facultés pas que je
vous laisse faire vous être le grand
maître à bord à l'éthique capital coeur
et bas comme d'habitude les gens
s'interroge beaucoup sur vous il ya une
question vous concernant voilà tout de
suite bien bonjour je m'appelle
christine l'autre jour pour commencer
l'émission
cyril hanouna s'est vidé une canette de
soda sur la tête
donc je voudrais juste savoir est-ce
qu'il est suivi médicalement
question je comprends votre question
chaque récit mais je vous rassure ce
qu'il va très bien comme le prouvent ces
images dont vous parlez ya une xbox a
gagné
cette partie yannick banques oui
j'ai bien vu les images
j'étais contrarié mixte pas que suis
content ça tout va bien tu fais gagner
une console de jeu tu traverses une
canette sur la tête c'est un minimum un
avis ce serait comme une console pas
proportionnellement c'est syrie présenté
le roi lion je pense qu'il mettrait des
départs pendentifs en fait si rien n'est
pas malade il a juste un problème avec
les canettes
c'est un homme fragile qui a besoin
d'affection je m'en suis rendu compte en
tombant sur ces images prises quelques
jours seulement avant l'incident
abou abel ou non les gars est non sans
regret on fait quoi après
le jeu
je
comme c'est le cri de calais redirai
qualité de la film d'horreur elle-même
va très bien à côté mais j'en ai eu une
nouvelle preuve en lisant le magazine
catholique le pèlerin à keith ridgway
vous avez accordé une interview pas la
fin je me suis régalé avec exactement et
nous est d'ailleurs une interview
poignante et honnête
ainsi lille comme on les aime regarder
le titre cyril hanouna le dialogue amène
au partage ah oui rien que le dit j'ai
tout de suite compris que j'étais tombé
sur une mine d'or
un style qui se livre comme jamais alors
le journaliste lui demande par exemple
quel est votre remède contre la déprime
et répond si reed en toute honnêteté
l'écriture à mon bureau
la lecture d'un roman de david frink 06
d'un livre d'histoire
tout ce qui peut apporter de l'eau à mon
moulin excusez moi de vous parler de
calme ou là exactement la grande
librairie en cachette
le seul truc que je vais garder dans ce
passage c'est une bd piqué à ma fille
le reste c'est caca ses mensonges autre
question lui devant quel est le comble
de la méchanceté sa réponse faire
espérer des choses qu'on ne réalisera
pas wen ça c'est le coup dur ça veut
dire qu'il va vraiment faire ce cover 2
la question finale qu'aimeriez-vous dire
adieu cyril s'il répond garder comme
c'est beau je crois en toi je sais que
tu as besoin qu'on t'aide aussi parce
qu'on ne peut pas tout attendre de toi
bon ça je crois que c'est un message
codé c'est ce qui est vrai que les
chroniqueurs lui disent bien reçu pas
trop symbolique au lycée conseiller en
communication il ya quelqu'un qui bosse
pour vous là c'est vraiment vous alors
acheter ce jour là j'étais au bout du
rouleau
non mais j'étais bien j'étais content
d'être découragée ils m'ont fait
ressortir des choses
j'adore le pèlerin d'ailleurs j'embrasse
tous les pèlerins bon journal l'observer
symbole dont on pouvait parler de ça
deux secondes je sais pas je regarde ce
que son conducteur n'a marqué gros zizis
provost qui met toujours des mots pas là
alors bien sûr à la ba oui au cas vous
êtes dans les confessions et que vous
êtes trop pudique pour tout dire je me
suis dit que moi aussi j'allais apporter
de l'eau à votre moulin
merci ce que vous savez dd je peux
j'essaie de vous faire découvrir un peu
plus de la vie de notre guide notre
rails la série lé secret mais de temps à
autre au détour d'un off
il nous en révèle un peu plus sur lui
écouter
et
la citibank et mat la cellule les a on a
une patience et à des groies sous
détient ce rappel sont jusqu il faudra
c'est ça comme mes coups et 85 c est
cool oui il faut savoir cyril a des
couilles 85 cents
mais jamais je dis ça parce que vous
aviez pour avec mon trésor oublié le
dire aux pèlerins
ça c'est un ami ça c'est un ami de vingt
ans
non mais il m'a demandé c'est bertrand
ce moment il m'a dit de dire des choses
sales dans sa seule amie de vingt ans à
brabois les balles est belle la france
à l'ailé comme il a des parties
génitales d'abord ils tentent des trucs
un peu fous
hier le grand journal recevait madonna
arrive donc cyril s'est dit qu'en face
il fallait envoyer du lourd
ouais ni une ni deux il a senti son
canada reste c'est appeler ma madonna
alors qui est sorti vainqueur de ce
combat de stars internationales
la réponse en images les eaux les
chiffres exacts au moment la prestation
de notre invité
ouais
c'est sûr
je vous racontais question s'est passé
ce soir au grand journal
bon j'ai rien contre antoine de caunes
non plus qu'il ya bien mais y est nous
avons un petit tacle je vous le dis
parce que dans le zapping
en fait ils ont passé madonna et ensuite
ils n'ont pas c'est madonna qui est
l'excellente issa et antoine de caunes
est sorti du zapping en disant toujours
préférer l'original à la copie
apparemment antoine n'a pas regardé les
audiences mais on aime bien quand même
un petit tacle alors toujours la même
famille et bon c'est pas grave à
l'enregistrer quoi et je pense qu'au
niveau rapport investissement efficacité
on ya gagné parce que pour cette
magnifique prestation au mas madonna
avait exigé dans sa loge une bouteille
d'oasis et des chips c'est vrai alors
que ben abdallah s'était fait c'est
comme ça leur a coûté quand même un
petit peu plus cher mais quand je vois
les deux images moi c'est une préférence
une fois j'ai une préférence il ça s'est
passé le meilleur actuellement c'est le
meilleur et il y avait une aura avant
qu'il tenait justement exceptionnel il
n'y a pas que siri dans l'équipe il y en
a d'autres qui ont des secrets et nora
est normal par exemple
alors regardez ces images et deviner son
secret serty je saurai vous avez dans un
restaurant à vous demander à d'autres
bars et on vous la met sur une assiette
et à côté à la l'élégance ans mais
franchement comment vous faites vous
alors l'ordre qui vous choque
si elle vous regarde non quel est son
secret ouais vous ai pas vu son secret
non non moi tôt
cette broche là maintenant ça vous avec
quatre chroniqueurs très bien allier qui
font tous la même taille comment est ce
possible
la réponse en images nous devons arrêter
jamais moi vous moi vous avez vous un
petit noeud papillon c'est magnifique
oui talons view oui mais si on peut
toucher
aulas c'est contre nous a fait nos
landes avec la petite bientôt ya un mec
qui va lui mettre un petit casino taille
et non un reste debout pendant
l'émission a secret encore plus
dérangeant maintenant attention cela il
va faire mal à quand un fruit pourri
menace le panier entier est de mon
devoir de dénoncer celui ou celle qui a
fauté à vous avez entendu parler du
swiss l'x de hsbc
bien sûr bas à côté ce que j'ai trouvé
c'est la gnognotte à une fraude
une arnaque dans le plus grave
lui que cyril bichonne parce que vous
savez très souvent jean michel est un
peu méchant et qu'ils avaient lui
reprochant notamment de danser pour un
oui ou pour un non
eh ben ce faire il a recruté nouvelle
chroniqueuse pour lui rendre la vie plus
belle nadège beausson diagne faye séjour
chez julien d'ailleurs un qu'il a acquis
l'art côté que voilà qui a eu le voile
avec une houle après qu'il eut et après
tout voilà prête à partir voilà qui nous
l'a présenté ou là on l'a trouvé très
simple on l'a en leasing alors non
seulement il est plus heureux mais en
plus ils commencent à avoir de
l'empathie pour les autres comme ici
gilles verdez regardez le
je verrai hussein débarrasser j'ai
récupéré mes dents
non
c'est tout
et
et c'est pas si vous avez remarqué moi
ce que j'aime c'est quand même notre
côté quai date et qu'il fallait pas y
être a débuté à la maison il ya rabi al
la totale à fond dans l'eau dans le trou
soit elle elle s'en fout totalement mais
c'est terrible parce qu'il est très
méchant mais en même temps il est très
vif sur le comprendre mais la vie n'est
pas facile pour jean michel quint ça se
voit peut-être pas mais depuis quelques
temps à l'antenne cyril a resserré les
boulons niveau vocabulaire mais c'est
m'arrive ça pour jean-michel mais c'est
le plus dur
regardez la détresse d'un homme qui voit
son monde s'écrouler
coût 10 plus gros boy spécial e monique
et maintenant on fait maintenant je ne
veux pas dire parce que son permis à
près de 7
serrer les boulons légaux les groupes
bombe min tit de dire
les copains
j'adore les deux les multicoques
j'ai même pas le droit de dire ça non
pas ça non pas ces notes qui vont
tourner rapidement il ressort serrer les
boulons quatuor est ce que j'aime bien
c'est greffer ben qu'est ce que je vais
dire à l'oreille situe à tardi jean
michel idiart nique et enlève 50 % celle
ci s'est fait interdire sa part buzz
l'éclair et complicité maintenant gérer
les moments de complicité
alors je suis déjà tombée montré des
bisous après un jeux mais des jeux
vouloir lui dire quelque chose derrière
ça va passionner julien regarder
révélée regarder la joue le jeu le
portugais pour la saint valentin c'est
bien
allez passons aux choses passent aux
choses allaient même genre les gaver de
la semaine a pour la spéciale années 80
et nora avait mis une petite robe
baseball avec un gros 90 dessus
quelqu'un de l'équipe technique va lui
devenir lui faire une petite remarque
humoristique
regardez bien la tête à droite jusque
jusqu'au bout et à ba3
vénère les aider
aulas dort plus d'argent nous recevions
miss france camille serme enfin quand je
dis heureusement bizarrement il vient
toujours quand je suis pas là ta mission
peu ça vous adore bah ouais mais je suis
jamais la barre heureusement demain ya
marine l'heure selon moi je viendrai ben
heureusement que jean michel est là pour
accueillir que l'ami surf regarder
m
merci merci la percée des verts eelv au
micro marche pas oui il ya des raisons
aux égouts les bonnes questions et
parfois de simples expressions visage on
dise plus que de longs discours la
spécialiste de l'exercice vous savez c
il est même morini-bosc isabelle comment
tout dans son coin car on ne donne pas
toujours la parole donc retour de
l'émission invisible avec madame je
commande tout qui tirait voilà moi par
exemple
oui non à l'échec
l'aventurière en chine avant de servir
les votes du public
il a raison ça c'est pareil pour miss
france est bon mais oui miss france
ariane brodier one man show ariane fait
sa mito on va parler aux feux de la
rampe ward ont visé juste aux feux de la
rampe
oui j'allais le dire si oui c'est pas le
temps de le dire je pourrais pas le bien
et c'est pour qu'ils arrêtent aux feux
de la rampe débarqué là là au feu de
l'as rome et c'est appréciable 6,04
riche et dans le neuf et m
elle est mauvaise mais on les aime bien
mais parce que vous êtes des vrais
gentils en vrai nom mais voilà je vous
le dis c'est vrai mais vous sur tout et
il n'aura est très gentille c'est vrai
bertrand ont pu avoir et surtout y'a que
des pourris un jour c'est vrai en fait
c'est presque du bois touche pas à mon
passé émission médias mais on ne fait
pas que ça on chante aussi
même si on connaît pas toujours les
paroles je lance cette semaine une
nouvelle rubrique le carreau presse
premier candidat jean michel maire qui
va essayer de suivre syrie sur une
chanson de tarkan si maric alors vous
savez c'est quoi c'est la chanson du
bisou voilà alors c'est une de mes
vidéos préférées la quinzaine
non mais regardez la concentration la
détresse de jean-michel tout ce qu'il
sait c'est qu'à un moment il faut faire
un bisou raisin le problème c'est qu'il
sait pas quand
marceau
bravo à une nouvelle question je crois
une dernière question à bonjour je
m'appelle geneviève parfois dans le
regard de jean michel maire on peut voir
du vide comme si c'était un coquillage
donc je voulais savoir si on colle son
oreille contre lui est ce qu'on peut
entendre la mère aujourd'hui jean michel
est un paradoxe vivant brillant
journaliste en tout cas sur sa page
wikipédia il connaît parfois quelques
absences sur notre plateau c'est aussi
pour ça que cyril a mis en place les
coups de coeur et les coups de gueule en
début d'émission pour impliquer
jean-michel parce que quand il ya un
truc qui me tient à coeur bat au moins
est là il est il et focus qui a dévalisé
c'est parti
comme le dit sénèque javel à berriac
puisque j'allais dire dans sa lutte il
rigole rémois secoue alémanique c'est
l'aele et magica bravo vous êtes un g10
et voilà il est quoi tant il est content
mais un peu trop de vite parfois quand
même mais le sillage du pire tout le
monde le sait ici sur le plateau
peut-être que les spectateurs le sahara
c'est quand thierry moreau ou quelqu'un
d'autre fait une vanne qui ne comprend
pas le pire c'est la désolation le vide
intersidéral ont le regard de jean
michel illien monde flottement j'ai
essayé de faire une copie pour geneviève
de tous ces moments de flottement tous
ces bugs de jean michel maire
n'empêche mari habitent en fait le seul
comique si c'est si c'est une capote au
genou rien ne passe africaine j tout
s'éclaire arthur ashe jamais c'est
vraiment pour le coup c'est accablant
préfère une tour de caravanes devant ce
beau ses coûts
est ce que je préfère c'est quand notre
focus verdict il avait à lui fait elle
lui seul un flot biwetz à son petit
frère attardé
oui mais je lui demande pas les mafieux
lettres de l'alphabet c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui journée tous applaudissent
composants